I love ice cream it's one of life's
simple pleasures but the science that's
much more complex at its core ice cream
is a product of phase transition in this
case water freezing into ice two things
that greatly impact the texture of ice
cream are the amount of the water in the
ice cream base that freezes and how
quickly that transition takes place so
one of the biggest challenges for the
home cook is making ice cream that is
dense smooth and free of noticeable
iciness what's interesting is that all
things being equal ice cream that we
perceive as icy doesn't actually contain
more ice crystals just bigger ones the
crystals and smooth ice cream are so
small that our tongues can't even detect
them there are two basic ways to prevent
ice cream from having an icy texture the
first is to control the water in the
base now this could mean reducing the
overall water content it could also mean
keeping more of the water in liquid form
by adjusting sweeteners sweeteners lower
the freezing point of the water in the
mixture preventing some of it from
turning to ice or you can use
ingredients like starches and gums which
trap free water and prevent it from
forming large ice crystals the second
way to prevent an icy texture is to make
sure that the ice crystals that do form
are as small as possible here we're
talking about rate of freezing the
faster you freeze ice cream the smaller
the ice crystals will be now commercial
ice cream manufacturers have a lot of
advantages over the home cook when it
comes to making ice cream they have
powerful stabilizers and professional
freezers and blast chillers that can
turn a liquid custard into a semi-solid
ice cream in a matter of seconds it's
not something you could do at home and
believe me an America's Test Kitchen we
try to so here are the ingredients for
our vanilla ice cream I'm using a
combination of heavy cream and milk for
the right level of richness that fat
also helps reduce the perception of ice
crystals by lubricating your tongue I'm
using fresh vanilla bean for its complex
flavor I'm going to add it early in the
process to get maximum flavor out of it
the next up we have the sweeteners which
have a huge impact on texture I'll come
back to that point in just a minute
here I'm using granulated sugar which is
pretty common and corn syrup which is
not a corn syrup is a combination of
sweet glucose molecules which make it
sweet and chains of broken corn starch
so it's these chains of tangled corn
starch which give corn syrup its
viscosity now in our ice cream they
prevent water molecules from group
freezing into big crystals so since
we're thinking about ice cream at the
moment let's imagine freezing it if we
cool it then we know that without the
sugar or salt the the temperature which
the the water becomes a solid at zero
degrees Celsius and that's because the
entropy of the water molecule is moving
around becomes balanced by the sticking
energy of water molecules to each other
to make the crystal if there's salt or
sugar in the water that salt or and
sugar has an additional entropy that is
besides the entropy of the water
molecules there's also an entropy of the
salt molecule so you can imagine these
little molecules jiggling around and
when you freeze the mixture you have to
also stop the motion of the solute
molecules of the sugar or salt and that
requires a little extra energy than you
would have had to give it otherwise so
this extra energy leads to the
phenomenon that people call freezing
point depression this is the notion that
if you actually try to freeze a mixture
of salt water or sugar water you have to
actually go to a lower temperature to
freeze it than you would if there were
no salt and sugar that lower temperature
is to actually put in the extra to get
rid of the extra energy that's needed to
actually stop to solute from moving
freezing point depression essentially
depends on the entropy of the solute and
as such what the amount that you have to
actually depress the freezing point
really depends on the number of solute
molecules per unit volume that you've
managed to put in the more you put in
the more the free the freezing point is
depressed if we think about this when
making ice cream it raises a bit of a
conundrum so if you make ice cream
you'll all recall or you will know soon
enough when you do the lab that the
recipe for ice cream essentially
involves taking milk which of course has
little fat globules and other things in
it it's basically water with fat
globules and other molecules and you
then pour sugar in the milk because you
would like to be sweet and then you need
to freeze the the sweet milk now if you
freeze the sweet milk by surrounding it
by just normal ice just normal frozen
water it won't freeze and the reason is
is because of freezing point depression
the mixture has a lower freezing point
than the water so somehow you have to
get the material that's around the milk
with the sugar in it to have a lower
freezing point
out of milk and a way to do that is to
add salt so if you add salt you of
course depress the freezing point of the
salt water if you then freeze that and
it will have a lower temperature than
the freezing point of the milk or a
sugar mixture and that will allow you to
freeze it and make ice cream so let's
let's see what it looks like so as you
can see it's nice and thick and dense
and I'll take a little try just to make
sure it's good and doesn't have any ice
that's good it's really nice and dense
very smooth and there's really no
noticeable ice crystals because we made
them nice and small so by understanding
and controlling the phase transition of
water to ice we get ice cream that's
scoop full right from the freezer into
dent its creamy and most importantly
perfectly smooth